One thing just about everyone in the
"Star Wars" universe can agree on is
that you don't want to wind up on the
business end of a lightsaber. But as
deadly as these weapons seem, some have lived
to tell the tale of being attacked with one.
When The Phantom Menace premiered in 1999, the
only thing that just about every Star Wars fan
could agree on was that Darth Maul was one
of the best parts of the movie. His signature
look frightened younger audiences, and his
double-bladed lightsaber changed the game forever.
Though he doesn't say a whole lot,
Maul's commanding presence makes
the character work. That final "Duel
of the Fates" sequence at the climax
of the film proved to all that this Sith
apprentice was a force to be reckoned with.
After killing Jedi Master Qui-Gon Jinn in brutal
combat, Maul nearly dispatches a young Obi-Wan
Kenobi as well. Pinning our hero down, Maul taunts
Kenobi, kicking his lightsaber into the abyss.
However, Obi-Wan surprises Maul and cuts the Sith
literally in two, sending him down into the void.
For years, it seemed as if Maul was
dead, though some Star Wars Legends
stories claimed he survived. This led to
his eventual resurrection in Star Wars:
The Clone Wars, where it was revealed
that Maul, now a cyborg, remained alive.
Voiced by Sam Witwer, Maul lived on with an
intense hatred for Kenobi and confronted his
nemesis on numerous occasions. Maul
also led the Crimson Dawn criminal
syndicate depicted in Solo, but was soon
side-tracked by his revenge. Eventually,
Maul was officially killed by Kenobi in Star
Wars Rebels, having finally found peace.
Few have gone through as much pain and
suffering in the Star Wars universe as
Anakin Skywalker. Be it emotional
turmoil or physical deterioration,
Anakin has undergone enough hardship
to last two lifetimes. For this reason,
it's somewhat fitting that he lived out two lives:
one as a Jedi Knight and the other as a Sith Lord.
In Attack of the Clones, Anakin and Obi-Wan
engage the Sith Lord Count Dooku in battle, and
though the young padawan has undergone rigorous
training, he was unprepared for this match.
As master and apprentice tackled the Sith,
Dooku gained the upper hand and took Anakin's
arm off below the elbow. Sending the padawan
backward, Dooku would've finished the job had
Master Yoda not arrived in time to fend off
the Sith Lord. Gaining a cybernetic limb,
Anakin recovers from his wound,
using his newfound robotic parts
to his advantage during the Clone Wars. He
even returns the favor to Dooku two fold,
by removing both of the Sith Lord’s hands
before decapitating him in Revenge of the Sith.
"It is only natural. He cut off
your arm, you wanted revenge."
Unfortunately for the young Jedi, later in
the film Anakin takes on his former master
on the volcanic planet Mustafar. After a
long duel, Kenobi gains the high ground,
removing both of Anakin's legs and his
remaining arm in the process. By the film's end,
Anakin is given more cybernetic replacements,
having now become the Lord Vader we all know.
Technically, Vader also lost yet another
arm to his son Luke in Return of the Jedi,
though he didn't live for very long afterward.
In The Empire Strikes Back, Luke arrives at
Cloud City to save his friends from Vader's
force-choking grasp, only to learn that the entire
thing is a set-up. Cornered by the Sith Lord,
Luke strikes back, and even lands
a blow on Vader's armor. However,
it isn't enough, and soon Vader overpowers
him, taking his right hand in the process.
Just as Anakin lost his arm to a Sith Lord in his
youth, Luke loses his hand to Darth Vader. It's
here that Vader attempts to sway Luke to the dark
side, and reveals the young Jedis' true parentage.
"No, I am your father."
Thankfully, Luke doesn't succumb to the same
temptations from either his father or the Emperor
that Anakin once did. Instead he resists,
finding refuge in his love for his friends.
However, like his father, Luke receives a
cybernetic replacement as a result. His wound,
paired with the capture of his friend Han Solo,
serves as a powerful motivator, and Luke acquires
all the skills necessary to become a full-fledged
Jedi Knight by the events of Return of the Jedi.
Luke soon establishes a new Jedi order, and by the
sequel trilogy, he remains unscarred any further,
at least physically, thus removing
his destiny from that of his father.
It may be surprising to learn that Obi-Wan Kenobi
has suffered some pretty deadly lightsaber wounds,
but fans of the Star Wars prequel trilogy
will likely remember these scars well.
During the same battle with Count Dooku that
resulted in Anakin's arm being chopped off,
Obi-Wan too was singed by
the red blade of the Sith Lord.
Early in the battle, Skywalker is incapacitated
with Force lightning forcing Kenobi to face off
against the Sith Lord alone. Given that this is
the second Sith he's faced, his training proves
true and the Jedi Knight fends off Dooku for
quite awhile. Unfortunately for Kenobi, Dooku does
eventually prevail and cuts him deep in the arm
and the leg. It is after Obi-Wan is injured that
Anakin faces the count again before losing his
arm. Yoda then must rescue the two younger Jedi.
Of course, this isn't the only lightsaber wound
that Obi-Wan endures. In the original Star Wars
film, A New Hope, old Ben Kenobi faces off against
Darth Vader, sacrificing himself to give Luke and
his friends the chance to escape. Though it's
debatable if the blade actually touches old Ben
or if he just disintegrates into the force, he
returns as a spirit in the sequel nonetheless.
One of the primary antagonists
from the animated Star Wars Rebels,
the Grand Inquisitor is at the top of the food
chain among the Force-sensitive Jedi assassins
known as the Empire's Inquisitorius. Having
been once trained as a Jedi Temple Guard,
the Grand Inquisitor fell to the Dark
Side and joined the Galactic Empire
after the end of the Clone Wars, committing
himself fully to the service of the Emperor.
Allied with Darth Vader, the Grand
Inquisitor helped exterminate Jedi
all over — at least until the events of the
Obi-Wan Kenobi series. In the Disney+ show,
the Grand Inquisitor is seemingly killed
after he's betrayed by Reva, also known
as the Third Sister, who shoves her lightsaber
through him in order to surpass him in power.
As a result, Reva is given his title
and he's seemingly forgotten. However,
it's later revealed that he survived due
to his thirst for vengeance. Eventually,
the Grand Inquisitor is given back his
title, serving under Darth Vader once more.
"Revenge does wonders for the
will to live, don't you think?"
Since Rebels takes place after the events of
Obi-Wan Kenobi, the Grand Inquisitor eventually
allows himself to die in a battle with Ezra
Bridger and Kanan Jarrus. Later on, it's revealed
that his spirit was redeemed, and he becomes known
as The Sentinel, a spiritual ally to the Jedi.
Speaking of Inquisitors, Reva too survived
a lightsaber wound. Even more impressively,
she survived mortal combat with Darth
Vader himself, twice. In Obi-Wan Kenobi,
we learn that Reva was a Youngling at the Jedi
Temple on Coruscant when Order 66 was given,
and she faced down against Anakin
Skywalker as he slaughtered her peers.
Somehow, she survived being stabbed by the former
Jedi Knight and grew to hate him. Deducing that
Skywalker and Vader were one and the same,
she planned to assassinate him for revenge.
As Reva and Vader battle, we see the full
scope of the Sith Lord's power. Eventually,
the Dark Lord stabs her again, seemingly
killing her, now for the second time. However,
she doesn't die. Somehow, Reva's rage and
connection to the Dark Side of the Force
keep her from death, and she soon flees
to Tatooine to kill Vader's only son.
Thankfully, she decides against slaughtering
a young boy in the same way that Vader once
attempted to kill her, leaving her
story open to be revisited again.
Of all the characters on this list, Reva's
survival is arguably the most outlandish.
It's one thing to survive a lightsaber
wound as an adult, but as a young child,
it seems just a little far-fetched.
Perhaps the Force — or the Obi-Wan
Kenobi showrunners — have big plans for
her in coming Star Wars installments.
Originally a main character from the
animated Star Wars Rebels, Sabine Wren
is a Mandalorian-turned-Jedi apprentice who
goes on a quest to find her long-lost friend
Ezra Bridger in the Disney+ series "Ahsoka."
Having been trained in the Jedi arts by Ahsoka
Tano in the years between Rebels and the Ahsoka
series, Sabine and her former master parted ways
some time ago. However, when Ahsoka needs her help
finding Ezra, Sabine jumps back into the fight.
Unfortunately for our heroes, they're not the
only ones in need of the map that will help
them find Ezra. It turns out the device
will also help some Empire-sympathizers
find Grand Admiral Thrawn. To get it
back, Dark Jedi apprentice Shin Hati
surprises Sabine, stealing the map
and engaging in a lightsaber duel.
During the battle, Shin stabs Sabine through
the gut, leaving her for dead. Though it
might have been easy to assume the worst, the
opening of the very next episode reveals that,
somehow, Sabine survived, with
only a small scar to show for it.
Strangely, unlike others who have survived such
intense lightsaber wounds, Sabine seems to have
needed no cybernetic implants. Whether
that's true or not remains to be seen,
but given the intensity of the injury, it
seems like there should've been some major
repercussions. After all, it's the same wound
that killed Qui-Gon Jinn in The Phantom Menace.
The only non-Force user on this list, General
Grievous is a cyborg and a major figure in the
Confederacy of Independent Systems. A serious
thorn in our heroes' sides throughout the Clone
Wars, Grievous actually first appeared
in the original animated Star Wars:
Clone Wars series ahead of the release
of Revenge of the Sith. By Episode III,
General Grievous was known as a notorious Jedi
killer who would collect their blades as trophies.
"Your lightsabers will make a
fine addition to my collection."
Although he's a major player
in the animated Star Wars:
The Clone Wars, Grievous' first feature
film appearance also marks his end. However,
he doesn't die at the wrong end
of a Jedi's blade. As a cyborg,
Grievous has the ability to withstand plenty
of physical damage, even lightsaber strikes.
While hiding out in a cave on a faraway planet,
Grievous is hunted down by Obi-Wan Kenobi,
who engages with the cyborg and
his droid army. In the battle,
Obi-Wan successfully chops off two of the
general's four cybernetic limbs. Though
he suffers no true injury, the loss of
his hands reduces his effectiveness.
Eventually, Kenobi does kill General Grievous,
but not with his lightsaber. After
losing his lightsaber in the battle,
Obi-Wan uses a blaster to dispatch the Separatist
leader. Despite his grisly death during the same
conflict, it's not the lightsaber that
kills him, making General Grievous one
of the most durable cyborgs in the galaxy.
Good thing Obi-Wan took him out when he did.
A direct descendant of Darth Vader himself,
Ben Solo fought to walk in the same footsteps
as his grandfather. After believing his uncle,
Jedi Master Luke Skywalker, tried to kill him,
Ben finds refuge with Supreme Leader Snoke,
a clone puppet controlled by the resurrected
Palpatine. After changing his name to Kylo Ren,
Ben became the new face of the First Order.
Thirty years after the end of the Empire, the
First Order had left its mark on the galaxy,
and the New Republic had
all but vanished. However,
a new hero rose up to battle against the Dark
Side: Rey. A young Force-sensitive woman,
who actually turns out to be the
daughter of a clone of Palpatine,
Rey forms a strange bond with Kylo Ren that turns
slowly into something more. Even after their
battle in The Rise of Skywalker ends with Rey
stabbing Ren through the gut, that bond remains.
Using a Force-healing technique, Rey keeps
Kylo Ren from death, fighting to resurrect
Ben Solo as well. Thankfully, she does, and the
two of them take on Palpatine together. However,
Ben eventually returns the favor to his
friend, giving his life in exchange for Rey's.
Okay this one is a bit of a stretch,
but Qui-Gon Jinn continues to live on
in some form long after plenty of other Jedi
have perished completely, so we thought it
would be fair to give him some credit here.
Primarily appearing in The Phantom Menace,
Qui-Gon trained Obi-Wan since he was a boy, and
planned to train a young Anakin Skywalker as well.
Unfortunately, those plans were foiled by the
Sith after the Trade Federation invaded Naboo.
As we already know, Darth Maul duels with
Jinn and Kenobi before they're separated,
and fatally stabs Qui-Gon in the gut.
Qui-Gon dies shortly thereafter, but not before
making Obi-Wan swear to train Anakin as a Jedi.
It's not until the very end of Revenge of the
Sith that Qui-Gon is mentioned again, when
Yoda reveals to Obi-Wan that his old master has
found a way to reach out from beyond the grave.
At the end of Obi-Wan Kenobi, Qui-Gon
finally reappears to his former apprentice,
ready to teach him the secret ways of the Force
so that he too might one day join him in the
afterlife. Admittedly, Qui-Gon doesn't technically
survive his lightsaber wound, but the fact that
he learns to make himself into an immortal spirit
following his death definitely gives him an edge.